نبقى في اخبار امريكا التقدم بالسن
والتلعثم ورقتان يداوم على اللعب بهما
منتقدون رئيس امريكي جو بايدن لترمى على
طاوله الترشح الانتخابات الرئاسيه كل حين
لكن الورقتين محروقتان حتى اللحظه
فاستطلاعات رايي اظهرت تقدم بايدن على
ترامب ب 44% مقابل 38 في المئه اما ميزه
هذا التقدم لبعيد على خصمه الجمهوري فردت
للناخبين المستقلين اي داعمين لمواقفه من
الاجهاض والعنف باستخدام السلاح لكن قضيه
المهاجرين الذين يعبرون الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قادمين من المكسيك تحمل
ايضا خطرا محتملا على رئيس بعد ان رفع
ادارته للبند الثاني والاربعين حيث فضل
64% من الديمقراطيين وثلاثه وتسعون في
المئه من الجمهوريين مرشحا رئاسيا يدعم
اجراءات اكثر صرامه لتامين الحدود
الاستطلاع نفسه اظهر تقدم ترامب على ديسان
الذي يتوقع ان يعلن ترشيحه الاسبوع المقبل
بفارق واسع اي 49% مقابل 21 في المئه لكن
للمفارقه كان بابداء نسبه عاليه من
المستطلعين عدم سعادتهم اصلا بمرشحي
الطرفين وفضل اذا 15% منهم التصويت لمرشح
اخر فيما امتنع تسعه في المئه عن التصويت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات